let's consider pretty much the most
stock standards exponential function you
can have y equals two to the X now I'll
just show them to consider any number to
wrap your head around while this to the
X as an exponential function where is it
going to begin if I said X equal to 0 X
equal 0 long laughs what are you going
to get the way I'm just going to get one
your index let's tell you that to go
ahead and along and he are pop in some
one now more point of the exponential
function is if the base is two then
every time you progress over one hidden
you're going to double I choose right so
if I go over to x equals one there why
don't you meet water too and very
rapidly if I go with x equals two you
start to run out of space station
because here's why but to if I believe
it but that it to the x1 is going to
come up to four to the white one
I don't know space within x13 cob r8 is
already off my graph so that's what's
happening to the right what's happening
to the left if I put in negative values
for X what's happening to to the else
yeah it takes more than four hours for a
log and further we go over here for
instance if I have x equals one and two
already plot on there well it makes
sense to put x equals negative 1 and
negative 2 if you think aidid goes well
we know what negative indices do when
you put them up in there to decide
negative 1 of course is uh-huh so did I
best here at the harbor yeah and of
course if we go over another set to the
power of negative 2 you're going to be
out great so just as we went from left
to right and these distances vertically
doubled and they got higher and higher
and higher
going from right to left the distance is
US Army I'll be good harden your car
your car your honey which is why no
matter how far you go you'll never
actually touch this x-axis plug on yeah
no matter how many times you harm right
eye you'll never actually get to do
you'll just get very very small numbers
ok so now we try our best to join up the
dots what you want to make sure is that
as you get closer and closer closer
your whoops sorry you're going to
approach the x-axis but never actually
collide with it so that makes y equal 0
the equation of our asymptotes and it's
important that you have a plan on there
okay go ahead
join the dots and let's see what kind of
victory then
okay now it's just a quick vote what
really happened with that I've done I've
done better I didn't quite get every
single one point but this is probably
fine
a lot of exponential graphs like this
you are expected to have a reasonably
accurate scale especially when I draw
draw a grid paper or if grid paper is
supplied to you so sometimes you get on
a on an exam they like to separate this
page out and draw a graph on it
if they give you grid paper that means
be expecting these distances to be
consistent and they're expecting these
distances here to be what they're
supposed to be on this graph so you
really have to have some sudden point
plotted on there
all right so let's label this time y
equals 2x now the heading of grass of
more drivet conscience and I tacked on
it from there because the best way to
understand blood functions is to think
of it in terms of exponential functions
here's what I want you to do I want you
to take your page unfortunately I don't
do this to the whiteboard I want you to
take your page and then I want you to
rotate it 45 degrees anti-clockwise 45
there is a dropper so now you're on axis
should be pointing like this right like
in an X rather than T okay then give
your graph in that orientation order on
the page on the table I want you to now
draw in in a different tolerance if
you've got it the line y equals x legal
okay now again keeping your page the way
it is I wish I could just turns over
okay
keeping your page the way it is I want
you to reflect the y equals two to the X
line reflect it across this y equals x
line that we've just drawn if you've got
like a free page there what you can
literally do is you can actually fold
your page along this line and then if
you press hard enough on the opposite
side of the page
you're going to get any impression
they're going to go over here that's
going through the reflection across the
Y of X then you're going to get a new
graph once you've got that new graph
could you take down the lookups on do
[Music]
[Music]
okay how'd you go does it look Rize you
can turn the background correct way now
what you should have is and you can you
can rotate your head to see mine ish
what you have created is the y equals
log base 2 of X line okay or the grass I
should say so you've got these pair of
functions that are related in this
symmetrical way what are the odds Emma
tree it's not even physically in
something else
you say it's a reflection my scales have
been off but you get the loner it's a
reflection across the Y to the X like
what always you can know that this is
what you created is take this equation
is y equals some color log base 2 of X
that is currently a log equation how
would you rewrite it to the Y if you
want to rewrite it as an exponential
equation we've got log terms X is going
to be the subject and it's going to be
to the power of Y so you see that the
relationship between this and our
original is you've taken the inputs and
outputs the X's of the Y's in function
notation and you have sort them like
which is why everything that was
horizontal like this asymptote for
example is there are vertical you see
that we've got a new asymptote here and
X equal zero and you do this behavior
over here instead of getting steeper and
steeper and steeper only hear you're
getting shallower and shallower yellow
forever does that make sense so the mode
function grows it was really really
slowly
there's no Aspen showed up here a basic
stop it will grow on forever
it takes a really long time so there's
your reference okay make sure you've got
your arm asymptotes then make sure it's
labeled that's really important make
sure just like you went to y equals one
you're going to go to three x equals one
now this log graph is going to be the
subjective to them I'm going to give you
a series of graphs that are related to
the transformations we had a look at the
end of last week you can shift things
around you can stretch and you can also
do all kinds of interesting thing if
you're willing to muck around with this
okay so for each of these I like this
little instruction underneath is
underneath this set of axes form so
graph the following and include there
are very three things that I'm looking
for for each of these graphs okay for
starters when you grab anything when you
go anything at all looks like the most
basic pictures of information you grab
it okay we've got intercepts right so X
or Y I should say and or y-intercepts
I'm just going to have a seat on there
now I want to actually talk about the
grasses yourself you're going to be
incest what other kinds of things how
look at those differences yeah okay so
did it as a joke to expecting an apple
okay now one thing that's a bit peculiar
to of this graph here is that I'd like
you to know
that was probably louder than you know
for each of these guys that we just done
do you notice the way we started was we
put a laborious amount of actual plot
points on here I do not expect you to do
that for the next few are going to ask
you draw however for that reason I want
you to notice that this graph here that
aren't that's draw this graph here could
be almost any exponential graph right
because almost all the parts to that
point and in the same way this could be
almost any blog graph because they all
pass through this point so you need to
supply a bit more information to tell me
is this little base to an X or the log
base 3 of X or one base 100 of X so what
are you going to need in addition to
this report you're going to need to have
some point to scale some kiwanis
unblocking point what everyone for I'm
going to color conscious there okay
the only thing I'll add is with only
unnecessary the only time you don't need
a point to scale is if you happen to
intersect with both axes intersect with
both then you can note oh I can here and
here that's got my scale both
horizontally and vertically but most of
them will not like the one that we've
drawn here so you'll need that so I'll
say unnecessary it's both actually
you